هكذا بدت المنطقه المحيطه بمجلس النواب
صباح يوم الاربعاء اجراءات امنيه مكثفه
لمواكبه الجلسه الثانيه عشر لانتخاب رئيس
للجمهوريه الجلسه ليست حاسمه لكنها
بالتاكيد مختلفه عن ما سبق وبسلاح العدد
والتعداد طلبت موازين القوى
بخلاف المرات السابقه حضر جميع النواب
فهذه المره الاولى التي يكون فيها مرشح
بوجه مرشح بدلا من حرب الورقه البيضاء
نواب اتو لدعم مرشح الاحزاب المسيحيه
والحزب الاشتراكي اضافه الى احزاب معارضه
ومستقله وعدد من التغييرين مقابل مرشح
محور الممانعه انتفاضه سياسيه برلمانيه
لتحرير لبنان من قبضه حزب الله من قبضه
محور الممانعه وقدرنا التقينا على شخصيه
ما بتنتمي لولا فريق من الافرقه وممكن
التفاهم مع على برنامج انقاذ اصلاحي هذا
المرشح هو مرشح عنده ما يكفي من مؤهلات
انه اولا يكون
بالايام اف مسؤول عن 30 او 40 بلد واليوم
يكون مرشح وملتقى لكل هالقوى السياسيه
جهاد ازوع
جهاد ازعر انتصر ازعور على فرنجيه بفارق
ثمانيه اصوات نتيجه تظهر ان حزب الله سعى
الى تقليص الفارق رغم طلب رئيس الطيار
الوطني الحر جبران باسيل عالميه من حزب
الله عدم التدخل بشؤون حزبه الداخليه
مرشحنا جهاد ازور انتصر اليوم والخط
السياسي الذي يمثله انتصر اليوم
والعمليه الانتخابيه مش لازم ناخذها
بحسابيتها على على الكالكوليتر لازم ناخذ
انه نحن شو اخذنا 59 صوت ولازم هن يحسبوا
قديش اخذوا والاهم ليطلقوا هذا الدرس انه
شو ما اخدوا واللي ما اخذوه كثير كبير
وهذا دليل مفصلي على رفض لنهج
الممانعه
باختطاف لبنان باتجاهات غير ديمقراطيه